cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent john dickerson
joins us now
this new article in the atlantic john
writes about the importance of
preparation for new presidents
this is a headline i love this headline
why you don't mess around with
presidential transitions
good morning to you john dickerson the
line after that is being president is a
tremendously difficult job
but you say this the article's great by
the way you said the presidency comes at
you fast
you write about the importance of the
president being prepared on day one the
moment he takes
the inauguration so what is what are the
most important parts of the transition
that needs to happen now
well the most important thing gail is
recognizing how little time you have
i started that article with something we
learned from president obama's memoir
which is that on the day he was being
inaugurated there was a terrorist threat
he had a passage in his speech that he
was going to
pivot to if the threat went forward
telling people how to evacuate
he was barely president and he was
already facing a live mass casualty
event
when you get into the presidency the
number of challenges on the national
security front in particular
are huge and and joe biden comes in with
a set of
challenges that's for any president joe
biden of course faces the pandemic the
economic unrest
uh and so he has a bigger to-do list
than
a normal president would now the
president says he has recommended that
this process began but he also says
i'm not going to concede what message
does that send and does it matter
by law he doesn't have to concede
no he doesn't have to concede it just
shows that on the way out of the office
the president is behaving much as he did
in the office there are a number of
things in the american tradition
that are done to sew up disunity when
things fray
there are easy routes that leaders can
take to
patch things back up again and it's what
keeps everybody unified and in this case
the president who has often
or perhaps always issued those things is
deciding on the way out not to do
uh what is normally done with a
concession which helps bring the
it's sort of an anesthetic uh that helps
after all of the division
uh and the reason that of course is
important as we saw in this election
just
how divided americans are and there's
only one way to make durable progress
and that's if people
work together so this is uh something
the president doesn't look like he's
going to do
which is just adds one more challenge
for the incoming president
you also write that the biden team that
we've seen so far is rich
in experience what does this tell you
about the direction that he's moving in
well it shows you that he believes in
things
if you look particularly at the foreign
policy team he's got
uh it he believes in alliances he
believes in
kind of the orderly way of doing things
on the national security front
now that's not a guarantee of future
success by any means
but what it does mean is that he
believes in experience
he believes in people who have been
through the washington
process before he believes basically
that if you're going to enter
a process of uh dealing in the world you
have to have people who have experience
in the world and so it it also suggests
people
that he's worked with a lot before so
he's got veterans of the joe biden way
of doing things again that's no
guarantee of success
but it is a vast difference than the
than the
sitting president who came to washington
to disrupt
to knock over the furniture joe biden is
setting that furniture back up
never good your mom gets mad when you
knock over the furniture i remember
those days thank you very much john
the article in the atlantic is why you
don't mess around with presidential
transitions thank you sir